E aí
[Música]
e fala sobre cérebro inteligência
pessoas comportamento me deixa muito
entusiasmados no estado vibrante mesmo E
isso não é de hoje não Por isso eu vou
resgatar uma história que me aconteceu
lá atrás quando eu tinha entre 8 e 10
anos de idade no meu colégio existe uma
noite de premiações uma espécie de noite
do Oscar onde os principais prêmios
distribuídos para os alunos eram aluno
matemática a uma relação e aluno de ouro
por algumas semanas só se falava disso
no colégio quem serão os premiados de
cada turno naquela época eu tinha dois
grandes sonhos o primeiro a ser alta eu
não aguentava mais as pessoas me chamou
de baixinha eu realmente achava que um
saco o meu segundo sonho era maior eu
queria ser inteligente desde nova eu
valorizo a inteligência humana e só ver
todas as pessoas que constroem as suas
histórias sendo assim eu queria mesmo
era ser gente inteligente e aí o colégio
ligava para os pais para avisar
e os alunos premiados para que esses
alunos vão faltar se no dia da premiação
né Então vem para que estes mesmos pais
pudessem contribuir assim na formação de
um discurso uma espécie de discurso na
hora da entrega do prêmio deste os
alunos e a minha mãe na tentativa de me
preparar Ela disse assim Lívia se você
ganhar o prêmio aluno aluna de ouro o
que você falar ah lá na frente e eu
disse para minha mãe mãe eu vou falar
nada esse primo não me interessa eu
quero prêmio de gente inteligente o
aluno de ouro era considerado uma
criança uma pessoa que tinha uma boa
comunicação uma boa escuta a famosa
simpatia sabe sobretudo que era amoroso
e para frustração da minha mãe eu não
fiz o tal discurso eu trouxe essa
história não é para focar em mim eu
sobre o prêmio e sim para falar de
conceito de Inteligência é que colocaram
nas nossas cabeças que um indivíduo tem
inteligente é só aquele que consegue re
as ações complexas de matemática ou que
sabe todas as capitais dos países da
Europa Fala Cinco línguas ou calcula
também o torque no sistema de alavancas
E esquecemos ou muitos de nós nem
sabemos que o simples fato de você
caminhar em equilíbrio ou amarrar o seu
cadarço são traços de inteligência isso
é muito importante é que estudar
Inteligência é que conceituar
Inteligência é um troço difícil nós
temos muitas pesquisas na área de
neurociências na área de psicologia na
área de genética E tantas outras áreas
contribuindo assim na construção de uma
uma ideia de um conceito sobre
inteligência que até hoje não se fechou
Nós temos muitos modelos com teorias da
Inteligência Nós temos muitos testes que
propõe a medir tipos diferentes de
inteligência e mesmo assim não há
consenso
e na década de 90 52 pesquisadores se
reuniram para definir inteligência e
definir um jeito que gosto muito
definido a inteligência assim
Inteligência é uma capacidade geral que
entre outras coisas existe sua
habilidade de raciocinar de planejar de
abstrair de resolver problemas aprender
rápido aprender com as experiências
percebam aprender com as experiências e
esse aprendizado não se refere somente
aos que estão nos livros opção
academicamente Restless vai além é um
conceito mais amplo mais profundo é
quanto de indivíduo consegue compreender
o seu entorno eu acho isso fabuloso
inteligente é o indivíduo que compreende
o seu entorno sabe quando você consegue
captar as ideias fazer conexão entre
elas e descobre sentido nelas tem são
traços de inteligência e mais né gente é
o divino inteligente é aquele que sabe o
que fazer com tanto conhecimento Afinal
nós não precisamos disso
o bumbum antes não é nós temos
dispositivos eletrônicos na palma da mão
24 horas para dar informação o que
precisamos mesmo então de pessoas
sensíveis com atitude um resolução não é
bom dentre várias funções complexas do
cérebro duas trazem discussões bem
interessantes razão e emoção e a gente
não sabe muito bem o conceito de
inteligência mas a gente sabe onde mora
a inteligência mora no cérebro ela
habita o cérebro que na espécie humana
tem um kg-200 um quilo e meio de peso só
na massa cinzenta que é o córtex a gente
tem 16 bilhões de neurônios o número
elevado de neurônios para primata dos
nossos Portes bom esse esse essa
vantagem numérica ela não custa muito
caro do ponto de vista energético é
muito o preço é muito alto para uma ter
todos esses neurônios energeticamente é
no cérebro que nós encontramos funções
sofisticadas
o raciocínio lógico raciocínio abstrato
é a capacidade imaginativa preditiva a
capacidade de fazer cálculos de
reconhecer padrão de ser emocionar de
ter memória bom talvez você já sabe toda
essa informação sobre o cérebro Mas o
que eu te pergunto é você sabe valorizar
o seu
e você sabe valorizar o seu você tem
escolhido fenótipos favoráveis para
cultivar esses neurônios bom dentre
várias funções complexas que o cérebro
tem como eu disse razão e emoção são
temas que geram discussões interessantes
Se você olhar no dicionário o
significado da palavra emoção vai estar
lá escrito é um Abalo afetivo eu vejo
essa frase eu escuto e fico pensando
naquele cachorro que fica correndo atrás
do rabo sabe quando fica dando voltas em
círculos dando voltas e Voltas voltas e
não chega a lugar algum é mais ou menos
desse conceito ele não me dá à luz então
se você procura um neurocientista para
fazer a mesma pergunta o que é emoção
eles vão ter a mesma dificuldade então a
neurociência tráfico em razão e emoção
são operações mentais que de certa forma
anguinha os nossos comportamentos e
diante de estímulos internos e externos
para nós é muito mais fácil associar a
razão aquilo que Racional com
inteligência
e é isso aqui é tão racional um
inteligente mas não então natural em
Curitiba assim para o ser humano
associar emoção e com inteligência
quando na verdade emoção é Fortíssimo
nesse construto precisamos falar de
emoção uma função somos emocionais à toa
eu tenho que pelo menos três razões e
importantes para sermos emocionais a
primeira sobrevivência a segunda
reprodução a terceira comunicação
imagine se nós não tivéssemos emoções
com raiva emoções como medo
comportamentos de agressividade como que
nós sugerimos de predadores ou como
seriam os pregadores um então esses
indivíduos que tiveram esse emoção que
ainda tem que com sorte chegam até a
fase reprodutiva se despertam para
emoções que leva a comportamentos
sexuais o que garante a perpetuação da
espécie e a terceira função não menos
importante é a comunicação Eu gosto
muito de associar Esta função da emoção
com a inteligência social
é imprescindível gente não é à toa que
no fórum econômico mundial na lista de
habilidade de profissionais do Futuro tá
lá Inteligência Emocional a inteligência
emocional tão comentada né nem sempre
bem trabalhada não cobram mas eu quero
um assunto mais quente eu quero falar de
algo mais quente que Inteligência
Emocional eu nem falar de coeficiente de
adaptabilidade parece que quando você
tem o melhor da sua soft Skills e das
suas formas Rios você tem um aumento do
coeficiente de adaptabilidade se adaptar
à mudança a empresa de habilidade veja
se isso não é uma característica dos
Mundos interessantes no mundo atual
claro que é não é estamos num mundo cada
vez mais tecnológico cada vez mais
complexo gosto muito da forma como Tiago
Matos traz isso para gente é o mundo
pensava digital é um do que é não linear
ele é muito disciplinar conectado ele é
exponencialmente imprevisível e
transversal como ele é complexo
o que parece que nós valorizamos tipos
diferentes de inteligência em épocas
diferentes da humanidade Então pergunta
vocês na época em que estamos distante a
complexidade tecnologia quem são as
pessoas mais inteligentes algumas coisas
estão certas a sua capacidade de
resolver problemas complexos o fato de
você ser analítico e crítico uma pessoa
sensível e que tem empatia são soberanas
e para isso nós precisamos inteligência
estratégia e isso tudo é isso mesmo nós
temos que melhorar a forma de estudar
tem que buscar estudos mais eficientes
estamos na era do Life long dur vinho
sempre atualizando constante estudo e
quanto mais você estuda mais repertório
você tem e mais capacidade de você tem
que fazer perguntas estão fazendo isto
faz tem um pesquisador um cientista
Brilhante de Nova York que fala que o
propósito de
É exatamente sobre fazer perguntas
perguntas Profundas e transformadora da
final é aí que mora o verdadeiro
trabalho então quanto mais você estuda
mais repertório mais capacidade de fazer
pergunta e por isso mais capacidade de
fazer conexão de ideias e pessoas Olha
eu dou aula há 13 anos e todas as vezes
que entro para sala de aula e em resumo
possíveis futuros com os meus alunos
Especialmente na área da saúde eles
ficam impressionados a gente fala de
revolução biotech os três principais
eixos A gente fala de genética a gente
fala de nanotecnologia robótica a gente
fala de machine learning Deep learning a
gente fala então quando fala de Big Data
que para mim dos nove pilares da quarta
revolução industrial para mim por isso
que têm um maior potencial nós temos um
mundo de dados esperando
tô esperando por quem esperando por
programadores sim mas esperam por mais
esperam por cérebros acurado sensíveis
críticos analíticos que saibam
transformar esse mundo de dados em
informações úteis para a tomada de
decisão por isso se revelam uma potência
para humanidade então quando a gente
fala de tudo isso no tecnologia meus
alunos ficam impressionados a gente fica
né Eu também mas eu quero trazer uma
experiência particular para vocês os
alunos ficam impressionados com
tecnologia assim mas o que mais impactam
meu aluno nada se iguala o que mais
Impacto meu aluno é quando eu levo para
sala de aula assunto sobre
vulnerabilidade social quando eu levo o
assunto de autoestima para dentro da
sala de aula quando eu levo a capacidade
de perdoar a coragem para falhar para
superar quando eu falo de inclusão isso
sim mexe com os meus alunos isso
impactou seja em pleno século 21 as má
é impressionante mas o que emociona
mesmo é falar de gente bom precisamos
abrir espaço gente nas salas de aula nas
salas de jantar e das nossas casas para
fazermos exercícios de divergência para
falarmos sobre o mundo da experiência
para a gente derrogar com a realidade
não adianta ficar comendo teoria tem que
dialogar com a realidade temos que criar
em nós um perfil cada vez mais
investigador mas colaborativo bom será
que o assunto que eu trouxe aqui hoje
tem alguma relação com você que tá E me
ouvindo Pai mãe filho professor-aluno
motorista enfermeiro Engenheiro diz que
sim porque esse mundo Complexo da
tecnologia tem transformado inclusive as
nossas relações de trabalho nós estamos
caminhando para o superjobs conceito
criado pela de lote em seu relatório de
2019 esse super de obras caracterizam
por cada vez mais uma exigência de
o YouTube e flexibilidade das nossas
habilidades técnicas e funções
Integradas das pessoas uma outra
característica bem interessante do super
empregos é automação cada vez mais
automatizaram automação fazer a
automação daquilo que era essencialmente
repetitivo e manual em tese isso nos dá
mais tempo o ser humano olhar para
demandas de caráter interpretativo e
analítico é como se fosse juntar assim o
melhor do mundo sabe o melhor da
capacidade humana com o melhor das
tecnologias vão na prática a gente vai
vendo como se funciona vai fazendo os
ajustes eu quero mesmo ter esperança eu
quero mesmo que todo tipo de
inteligência possa trazer para nós o
mundo como um lugar melhor para se viver
e mais tempo para lá
e talvez seja no meu pensamento falei a
será bom eu não trouxe respostas mas eu
vim com perguntas quem são as pessoas
mais inteligentes no mundo pode digital
será essa pergunta importante será essa
pergunta inteligente bom deixa aqui o
meu convite para essa reflexão muito
obrigada